Learner A3: مستر أسامة.
Learner A6: يا هلا يا هلا أيوة ما شاء الله.
Learner A3: كيف الحال؟ يا روغل عليك يا روغل.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A6: والحمدلله.
Learner A3: العفو.
Learner A6: بص هو.
Learner A3: عندي.
Learner A6: بس يعني صارت إدتني حرفيا. قضيت رحت أعمله.
Learner A3: بالله عليك.
Learner A6: يعني يعني أنا أنا بصي عليه إن أنا
Learner A6: بدأ إنه يخلص بس يعني إن شاء الله هجرب حالا هجرب.
Learner A4: طيب الله يطمنك الله يطمنك.
Learner A4: طبعا.
Learner A3: شفته اللي أنت شفته كان كويس.
Learner A6: هي برضه حتفضل المشكلة مشكلة مش متظبطة بسبب الموديل.
Learner A4: الكلام على إيه.
Learner A3: ما إحنا عملنا ما إحنا جابولنا لايت رجعوه تاني.
Learner A6: مع.
Learner A3: كما.
Learner A6: ما أنا مش عارف أعمله إنتاج عندي.
Learner A3: لذيذة.
Learner A4: السلام. على إيه.
Learner A6: أنا.
Learner A4: بالنسبة.
Learner A3: تعصب.
Learner A6: بي إم.
Learner A4: متعصب.
Learner A3: خلي بالك عشان عشان إحنا مش خليولك عشان.
Learner A4: أهلا وسهلا.
Learner A6: إن بي أم رواج.
Learner A4: عادي يعني مع تيم عادي يعني ما فيش موضوع.
Learner A6: ليه.
Learner A4: النقطه عندي ان هو انا ويقولي فين ذي أتيت مش أقل المشكلة فين.
Learner A4: أو المفروض في الترمينال هيطلعلك المشكلة فين بالزبط.
Learner A4: بتاع الفوائل واني لاين والكلام ده.
Learner A4: المشاهدين.
Learner A6: وخلصتش بور.
Learner A4: الله أكبر.
Learner A4: قزازك البني ولا ذكي.
Learner A4: ربنا يبارك استنى يا عمي. شغال عمي.
Learner A3: لا.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A6: بس بس.
Learner A3: صاير كده.
Learner A6: بشيرهم في نقطة بس عامله كله
Learner A6: نخليه فول باك لجيمناوي عشان كان واقع فكنت مخليه فول باك قبل كده يعني.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A6: هي دي النقطة بس إن كل هيبقى نقص لو رجعنا فإن شاء الله أعتقد هيدينا نتائج كويسة جدا يعني.
Learner A4: يا عم ده هو فايل في حنشيل بس وخلاص هو حيفضى شغال
Learner A4: أنا أنا بس يعني نفسي اللي انت تديني التعديلات بالظبط.
Learner A6: والله يستعمل شوية أنا معرفش بص يعني وش اللي حصل وأنا بسيبه يعدل براحته فعليا.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A6: أيوة حلو حلو قوي.
Learner A4: حلو الكلام ده أوي نزل شوية.
Learner A6: جلبت هنا.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A6: دكتور مرسي دول.
Learner A4: نزل نزل البتاعدي شوية نزلها شوية.
Learner A6: ماشي دي كدا.
Learner A4: ده.
Learner A6: الحالية. ما هو أنا كان في كم حاجة عملتلها بوش قبلها.
Learner A4: أه.
Learner A6: يعني.
Learner A4: اسم البرانسي فاينر.
Learner A4: الله يسلمك طال عمرك.
Learner A6: استنى كده اتأكد بس إنو طلع هو مفروض كده يخلص ماشي
Learner A6: هل جابلي هنا مشكلة في الكوتة أو حاجة؟
Learner A6: ما فيش أي مشاكل أهو طلعلي كل حاجة.
Learner A4: كله.
Learner A3: خرجنا باشا خرجنا فرغنا شهر.
Learner A6: مش هنا كده مش تنبتس نرجع نرجع.
Learner A3: صح.
Learner A6: نرجع فين الداتا شكسب فين الذاتي.
Learner A6: التلاتة دي ريندرز المفروض ده آخر فوائد صح؟ 9 وتلات دقائق فين آخر فوائد أوف.
Learner A4: رابع 1.
Learner A6: بس نبدأ.
Learner A4: الله، ومرة وحدة.
Learner A6: ما أنا قلت بقى حاجة كده برا كل.
Learner A4: الدنيا.
Learner A4: جبن فيتش دي.
Learner A4: أنا بهير انبهر.
Learner A4: لا إله إلا الله.
Learner A4: الكاثوليك.
Learner A6: يعني ممكن الأنيميشن بس.
Learner A3: يلا جينا من.
Learner A6: بولت سيكل.
Learner A4: ده كله يتظبط بالكلام ده بالفرنس والكلام ده.
Learner A6: ما بالزبط يعني ان شاء الله الشهرة.
Learner A1: جميل جدا.
Learner A3: فين بشمون.
Learner A6: بقول.
Learner A3: العظيم.
Learner A6: عموما يعني هو نفس الأسد وعمال.
Learner A4: 13 دي الوقت ماشي طيب الاسس دي معمولة من الإيفين بتاعهم صح؟
Learner A6: جرت اهو إيه بشرى.
Learner A4: ده حلو.
Learner A6: أنا دخلت.
Learner A3: اللهم خليل.
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A3: لا.
Learner A6: كذا ديتس.
Learner A4: طيب ده أسد جمريتيد فروم ذي فرينتي أند أور ألريدي فروم ذيجنس بل.
Learner A6: يعني.
Learner A4: أيوة إسأل هنا المعلم ده يسلم علشان.
Learner A6: أو.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A6: فين أدي أول مرة نيت أول شي أنا ماشي.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A6: وظيفة.
Learner A4: لا ده.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: ده تمام ماشي.
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A6: فيلتو أبلور.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A6: أور إل ده كانت تقريبا.
Learner A4: ليفا.
Learner A6: لا والله عشان هيك.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A4: اعمل اعمل فيليكت على.
Learner A6: يطلع من أول هنا وعند كل كده.
Learner A4: ومال كونترول.
Learner A6: كنت روسي بحطو فين بقى لا.
Learner A4: إنت إنت متأكد إن إنت أخدته كله.
Learner A4: ماشي في النص ماشي اعمل طيب كونترول.
Learner A6: بيعملوا كاملا.
Learner A4: مع خدو انزل ايوا انزل كابوس.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي شغال ماشي كم لحد ده كنترول بقى.
Learner A6: كنترول
Learner A1: إمرأة.
Learner A4: هيحطه في عملتوا. عملتوا. كنترول لي.
Learner A6: مدرسة كونترول.
Learner A4: وانت عملت سيليكت وانت عملت سيليكتس مش تعمل كوفي وبعد كده كنت.
Learner A6: أيوة أيوة أيوة.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي اضغط اضغط على اضغط على.
Learner A6: من شرف.
Learner A4: قوله على حوار الأكل قوله معمولة من ال إي جنت ولا معمولة من.
Learner A6: كده.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A6: بسم الله ده غبي قوي مقارنة ب كلود أوغست أو القديمة.
Learner A4: عامة مشكلة كبيرة يعني في.
Learner A1: بالنسبة.
Learner A4: بدكم.
Learner A1: العمر.
Learner A1: قالت لي الزبادي معمر.
Learner A1: كنت عايز ت اللي وضحها.
Learner A4: ماشي أعمل.
Learner A1: إمم.
Learner A4: طيب أعمله كوست ثواني ثواني طيب يا احمد ثواني.
Learner A6: ده بيحاول ينزلها جوز ستورج زي قريت ليميت أوكي.
Learner A4: ألو يسلمك ليه.
Learner A6: هو رجع فيكتور أي كوميديا.
Learner A4: يا سيدي ميرسي.
Learner A4: انتو.
Learner A4: يعني المشكلة.
Learner A6: أنا ممكن أكون أنا مش مزبط السكريبت ولا
Learner A4: انت حاطط.
Learner A6: يخش علي.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A6: ألز.
Learner A4: هو ده المقصود.
Learner A4: موارد.
Learner A4: يعني إنت إنت ليه مش حاطط اللايكل في آي تي.
Learner A4: أصلا.
Learner A6: إيه مع أنا مكنتش حاطه هنا إيه سكنت.
Learner A4: ما هو أنا بياخدو من هناك.
Learner A6: جاسم ملك
Learner A6: أفتكر إنه والله عمال يعني عمال حرفيا كان مع إنت جرافيتي وأنا مش فاهمة بيعمل إيه.
Learner A4: يا عمي، استنى استنى بدلا ما انت.
Learner A6: تمام ماشي.
Learner A4: هود يبعتولك.
Learner A6: أنا في إزاي وأنا أعمل شيرين.
Learner A4: ممكن بس تغير الموديل.
Learner A6: غير مذلة.
Learner A4: هم بيقولوا فتحوا حاجات زي موناي كلها.
Learner A6: من.
Learner A4: اللي.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: هو انت اللي انت بعته ده المفروض الواحد.
Learner A6: والنعم.
Learner A4: انت لو حاطط لو كنت حاطط فيرومنت الكلام ده هتلاقيه
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A4: الكونفريغريشن هي واخدها من النوم.
Learner A4: فرنش.
Learner A6: هو عموما بيقول إن هو شغال فعلا مند على طول يعني هو بيجيب الحاجات دي من ال باك اند مش
Learner A6: مش البروتس.
Learner A4: رتب والصور الصور بتخزن فين
Learner A4: ولا ثور مش بيتخزن أصلا.
Learner A6: هو لا هو غالبا مش بيخزن سوق بيديكي الأتش تي بي اسو بس
Learner A6: هو بيديك اللينك بس وانت بتستخدمه هنا. على طول
Learner A6: أنت الموديل أنت المودن تبغى غيروا ليه بالظبط.
Learner A4: استنى يا عم اهو؟ لا تدفع امك يا عم.
Learner A6: ليه.
Learner A4: أوريان.
Learner A6: ظاهرين عندك اللي أنا لسه عاملهم حالا.
Learner A4: لا بس في ظاهرة في الأول مكنتش ظاهرة.
Learner A6: اها.
Learner A4: في في كذا صورة.
Learner A6: بيقولك الدات نفسه ده دوت في الأسدي مش الأسد.
Learner A4: والبطالة والأودي. فايلز كلها تستخدم زي الفول حلوة والله علينا والله بجد.
Learner A4: يجب.
Learner A6: الإيميل ما بيتخزنش عندك المفروض صح؟
Learner A4: اتش تمل لا ما فيش أي حاجة ما هو انا عايز بقى
Learner A4: آخذ الكلام. ده إسألوا هل دلوقتي أخش ولا لأ؟ قل له دلوقتي.
Learner A6: بس دي.
Learner A6: في حاجة اننا الصورة قالتلي مش عارف على كمية تعديلات كدا هوت أنا مش عارف بصراحة بس.
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A4: هي ليه بقت بتتكلم عربي.
Learner A6: مع استنى بخير بجد على فكرة حوار.
Learner A4: هي ليه ليه بقت بتتكلم عربي.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A4: أي حاجة.
Learner A4: ما مش هيدلف، فأنت مش عارف الكلام مبادئ. من أين.
Learner A1: هي.
Learner A4: قريب إيه واللي.
Learner A6: الفكرة. أنا تقريبا مفروض أنزل.
Learner A3: ده التعليل لإنت لسه مصلحه يعني دي دي القصة.
Learner A6: ما هي دي أساسا اللي كان بويز يعني هو ده اللي بعثتهولي فكان.
Learner A3: أنت لسه مطلعه تقريبا انت وعمر.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A6: عندك مظبوطين جدا يعني الفاضل التثبيط الافتراضي في مش عارف إيه فرنش
Learner A6: أنا بجد المشكلة مش عارف اعرف مين مين أول حاجة ومين تاني حاجة متأكد إن.
Mentor A: يا سلام.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Mentor A: بس إنتو ممكن تقولولها تردوا الإنجليش
Mentor A: عادي يعني هي برضو ممكن عادي ممكن.
Learner A4: وحضرتك موجود من ساعتها يعني.
Mentor A: من حظك ممكن تقوللها ممكن تبعتلها كده يعني سيدة اسمها صدق إنجلوس.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: شو فات ردت ألك
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A6: بعتها دلوقتي يعني ولا.
Mentor A: أه أجرب.
Learner A1: المهم بس يا عمر حتة اليو آي دي وضحالي.
Learner A4: طيب أنت محتاج فيها يعني عشان تعمل.
Learner A1: بتقولي محتاجين. نوضح بتاعت يو آي وازاي بتتربط مال أنتم انت.
Learner A4: أنا عامل الكلام ده على.
Learner A1: شكرا.
Learner A4: علمي.
Learner A1: الميل.
Learner A4: على مين أهو على مين برينس ولو.
Learner A6: بالضبط.
Learner A1: الكلام كله عربي تقول لي كل شيء منظمه جدا والبتاع.
Mentor A: نفس الحاجة ثاني.
Learner A6: أنا قلت لها السيدة إنجليش هو هو
Learner A6: يعني تقريبا غيرت بس كم تبنى.
Mentor A: أوكي ممكن بابيها بس نيت والله يعني.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: ماشي طيب عامه احمد خذ اخر برانش. انا عملت له ببليس عملت له كومات على جيب
Learner A4: وانا بعترفشنز على سيركل فخدها و في ده يعني لو شغال مثلا او كده
Learner A4: ده جزء ال يو اي اللي انت محتاجه مني؟ اتوقع ففي حاجة تانية برضو بقوله.
Learner A1: نعم.
Learner A4: الجزء الثاني إحنا الحمد لله بنطلع فيديوهات الجزء ده بتاعت داون لود.
Learner A4: أنا لسه ما اخدتش الفاينل برودكت من من أسامة. هو يعتبر خلاص خلصوا بس بحل الحاجات بتاعت الصورة اللي هيبعتها
Learner A4: وبناء عليها أبدأ إن أنا أعمل يعني مع ريموشن
Learner A4: وان شاء الله حوار ده حيبقى سهل يعني ما فيش مشكلة.
Learner A6: يعني هو دلوقتي هو فعلا اللي هو عامله.
Learner A6: بيطلعوا لنا كل ستاجز السكريبت تمام الجسم بتاعه تمام.
Learner A3: ممكن.
Mentor A: أنا أشوف أنا أشوف.
Learner A6: الى كل.
Learner A4: والرينا.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: أو.
Learner A4: اللي.
Learner A3: أنشط.
Learner A6: ماشي تمام.
Learner A4: اها.
Mentor A: نعم، مش سامعة شو.
Learner A6: شوب.
Learner A6: ثواني باي رأيت الشيخ سعيد.
Learner A4: كوليستير، أنت تعمل.
Learner A6: وأشغل الصوت إزاي منه.
Learner A4: وإنت بتعمل.
Mentor A: لما تعملش.
Learner A6: ليتك يا فندم.
Learner A6: فيتشرز.
Learner A6: تمام ماشي شغال كده.
Learner A6: دوك توداي وير فينغ أوف جكتور بروجرامينج وير أل بي أوبجيكتس إن كلاسيس نمبر ون إن كابسوليشن أند.
Mentor A: نعم، الحمد لله.
Learner A6: إن.
Mentor A: ال.
Learner A4: 1.
Mentor A: عشان نتورك عندي.
Learner A6: إيش رأيك.
Mentor A: شوية.
Learner A6: براونت.
Mentor A: أكيد.
Learner A6: إنجليش.
Learner A4: إحنا سامعين إيه اللي عم.
Mentor A: لا.
Learner A6: والصوت عالي فعلا الفيديو.
Learner A3: و
Learner A6: على.
Learner A3: شوية.
Learner A6: نفسه.
Learner A3: يعني ربوتك شوية بس شغال حلو يعني.
Mentor A: أنا مش عارفة يعني الصوت الصوت بيجري أوي عن الصورة وكده فابعتهولي على.
Learner A6: يعني هبعتوا.
Mentor A: بدنا نترك إيش هو يعني بس مش أكتر.
Learner A6: ماشي هبعت رسالتين.
Mentor A: ماشي.
Learner A6: نعم،
Learner A6: وده الجسر الأخير هو مش هبعته برضو هبعت الجسر أون فاين على شان
Learner A6: بعتها برضه دلوقتي طلع.
Learner A3: هذا.
Learner A4: والله.
Mentor A: هو ليل لنفس الصورة في كل حتة.
Learner A6: الناحية دي بس كانت مشكلة نفسها عشان الموديل كان في مشكلة
Learner A6: هي ديت المشكلة اللي كانت الصورة.
Learner A4: وإحنا حلال.
Learner A6: سعد.
Learner A4: يعني على.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب فيري إمبريسي حلو جدا.
Learner A6: هو ممكن في 1 قبله برضو مطلع.
Mentor A: في.
Learner A6: شوية.
Mentor A: ومعاش معاكي كلهم لأ حلوة قوي أوي
Mentor A: هو الكومنت الوحيد أو يعني ممكن برضه في كذا إينسايد بصو هي في الأول. هي الإنتراكشن دي يعني اللي هي الحتة اللي في الأول اللي هي الثانيتين دي اللي بتطلع التايت
Mentor A: ما تتكلمش فيها مش عايزة كلام فيها يعني تتكلم من بداية يعني إنتو يعني.
Learner A6: من.
Mentor A: دي بدالها تبقى ميوزك عادي ميوزيك كده انت ميوزيك
Mentor A: وبتختفي بعد كده تيجي تتكلم بقى بعد بعد ما تيجي تروح
Mentor A: مش هي قعدت تتكلم كتير قوي فيها ودي إنتو يعني.
Learner A6: ايمتى.
Mentor A: فظيع.
Learner A6: عدل بس في نفسه. هو أنا سايبه في بيتكلم في كوليتيكست فأنا ممكن أخليه في التملك يقول بس أول جملة اللي هو إيه اللي إحنا بنتكلم عنه بس.
Mentor A: هو ما يقلش ما يقلش حاجة خالص يحط ميوزك.
Learner A6: طب تمام.
Mentor A: كم بس كده فهمت يعني
Mentor A: صح ممكن نحط كليب تلات ثواني مثلا على حسب الطول بتاع دي وهي بتظهر صح.
Learner A6: وتقريبا.
Mentor A: بس.
Learner A6: كده هوت يعني تبقى ستاتي إحنا حطينا يحطها في كل اللي هتبدأ صح؟
Mentor A: أيوه ما قلت إن.
Learner A6: واه بالزبط ماشي دي سهلة بإذن الله.
Mentor A: طيب أوكي.
Learner A6: آخر 1.
Mentor A: ميش.
Learner A6: هو ده كان بيطلع شوية أسست تانية.
Mentor A: أم نفس الكومنك برضه هي بتتكلم في الأول كتير أوي.
Mentor A: يعني ده سين أصلا لوحده يعني مفروض يبقى سين لوحده بتشرح في إنتو.
Learner A6: بالزبط. هو هنا أنا كنت حاسو مطلع أسد أحسن كتير بس يعني ال.
Mentor A: أيوه حلوة.
Learner A6: بس هنا عشان بقى كانت هي دي الفكرة إنه كان مستخدم في فبعد. ما.
Mentor A: يسمعوه عشان أنا المؤرخ فؤاد
Mentor A: كريمز فيري إمبريس غد حلو أوي.
Learner A6: ده لآخر 1 صح؟
Mentor A: هو بس برضه الكومنتس يعني ممكن تخلوني اشير ايس كريم كده.
Learner A6: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: يعني الرقم
Mentor A: أوكي سيفين سأخلص العيني.
Learner A6: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي أنا طبعا مش شغلة الصوت آلة السفر فوق سبحان الله
Mentor A: ميشيل سامعيني صح؟
Learner A6: أم.
Mentor A: ماشي بص مثلا هي بتتكلم هنا عن كومبسوليشن هو بيرفكت يعني بيرفكت بيرفكت
Mentor A: اللي في دماغي كان يبقى عامل إزاي إن هو يبقى في مثلا كبسول هنا
Mentor A: والكابسول دي مثلا في مثلا هنا مثلا يعني حاجات كده
Mentor A: كور مثلا بتدخل جوا كابسون دي.
Learner A6: إمم.
Mentor A: هل دي حاجة.
Learner A6: هو الفكرة نفسها إنه الأسد اللي إحنا مستخدمينه هو يعني إحنا بنجيبه كصورة اتش تي تي بي إس يعني أو يكون كده هوت بناء على الوصفة بتاع السين،
Learner A6: فإحنا مش منستخدم الصور بتاعت.
Mentor A: طيب هل ينفع الجنراليت حاجة أف بي جي مثلا أو مش إف بي جي آي أف.
Learner A4: هي الفكرة.
Learner A6: كل شي.
Learner A4: الفكرة اللي حضرتك قصدك عليه ده شغل يعني بتاع يو ايو اك صريح او بتاع مونتاج
Learner A4: يعني ال إي آو يفكر بالكريتيفيتي دي تباه.
Mentor A: عادي ينفع وإحنا الجوكس دلوقتي.
Learner A4: في في حاجة طلعت كدا حضرتك شفتي حاجة طلعت كده.
Mentor A: أنا بقول أنا بقولك دي حاجة ما بتتعملش ما هو ده إحنا شغالين بنطلع حاجات
Mentor A: إنت بتشوف مثلا في غبس في حاجة زي كده ما طلعتش فأنت لو طلعتها جامدة جدا، فاهم.
Learner A4: ما.
Mentor A: حركة.
Learner A4: على فاهمة.
Mentor A: الأول إن دي حاجة مش يعني مش يعني مش معمولة.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: اسمعي، تيكستوليشن.
Learner A4: كبسوليفن و بي في لا ام كابسوليشن أوف أو بي الكستوليشن برنسول ين.
Mentor A: الله يعافيك.
Learner A4: ينفع اديكو كمان.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: حلو اللي حضرتك هتعمليه دلوقتي ده تمام ممكن يطلع ال فاينل أوت كوت اللي انت عايزاه.
Mentor A: ماشي ما ده اللي قصدي عليه يعني أنا مش حاسة تخيل نفسك إن إنت قاعد مع يعني
Mentor A: قاعد في وسط حد بيبص فأنت بتقله ده
Mentor A: ماشي وجايب له صورة لو في حاجة رايحة جاية فخلي بالك
Learner A4: جدا. أنا مش بختلف مع حضرتك.
Mentor A: حتة زيارتن مثلا حتة زي الإنهرس كنت مطلع ثري يعني فيجوال صح مطلع طري فيها حاجات
Mentor A: محطوطة على بس تبقى أحسن لو إنت طلعت الثري كده في حاجة فوق وبعد كده عملت.
Learner A4: صح ما ما والله أنا مش بناقش في الجزئية دي
Learner A4: الحاجة الوحيدة بس اللي أنا بتكلم فيها اللي هو هو كده يعني
Learner A4: لما هيروح يبعث البروم على حسب التوبيك
Learner A4: يعني هو مش عارف نحن نتكلم على هتبقى أسهل للصفوفة اللي هي تبقى عاملة زي الفل والفل جواها معرفش
Mentor A: لا معلش.
Learner A4: يعني.
Mentor A: أنا أكمل.
Learner A4: حاسس إن دي هيومان كريتيفيتي هيبقى صعب اللي هو كل مرة نوفيد فيها بناء على الصمت اللي جاي.
Mentor A: عادي عشان إنت بتبي أنا بحس لما بعمل بعمل بيه حاجات عموما بحسه
Mentor A: عنده فك عنده حتة ديزاين دي شوية.
Learner A4: بني يعني مش عارف ممكن.
Mentor A: هو إنت هو إنت الفلوس ده عشان يطلع حتعمل إيه يعني وتبعثها طلعلي دوت جي إس وتعملوا مع صح.
Learner A4: هو أنا بالنسبة لي. أنا من وجهة نظري عايز نودي أدربه مش هيبقى.
Mentor A: لين.
Learner A4: ممكن.
Mentor A: ما أعرفش أنا بجرب معكم دلوقتي. أنا بجرب ده ممكن تطلع إزاي. أنا مش بقول لكم حاجة.
Learner A4: أيوة. ما هو مهو يعني هو في في اللي بيروح ويجي يعني اللي بيطلع منين المفروض من الفايل بتاع عمر ولا منين
Learner A4: عمر.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A4: بتاعك اللي بيطلع.
Learner A4: إن استناولك شي رند أسيد ببطلين.
Learner A4: بالطبع.
Learner A4: اللي.
Learner A4: ولا.
Learner A4: منين. ما هو بياخد منين بياخد من واي صح ولا أسس بي واي.
Learner A4: أيها أيها صح؟
Learner A4: القديمة.
Mentor A: أم
Mentor A: هو الصدق؟ لا، ما.
Learner A1: و.
Mentor A: فهمت
Mentor A: حاجة كمان برضه حتة البرنسكريبشن اللي تحت دي فمغطية على الإبداع.
Learner A6: تمام.
Mentor A: مغطية على السين يعني واضح جدا
Mentor A: يعني
Mentor A: ما فيش هو أصلا طلعها مش بيجي.
Learner A6: تقريبا هو الفكرة اللي ممكن تتعمل إننا يديله الصورة وهو يطلعها كفيديو
Learner A6: بس تقريبا أنا مش عارف هل في حاجة معنا في الجنراليت فيديو أساسا ولا.
Mentor A: ، في.
Learner A1: السودان.
Mentor A: هي ما أظن إسمها شوف بس هو تقريبا غيروا اسمه إسمه مغرفك ميرسي بيديك تصفية
Mentor A: هذا يوم خبز التاليتس
Mentor A: بنت يرجو ماشي هو ده زي بلاتفورم كدا في نماذج كتيرة يعني بتديك أ بي آي
Mentor A: كأنه سيرتبورتكت مش بي آي فيها فيها فيو ثري بتاع غوغل وفيها فيها كيلينغ فيها فيها كذا حاجة فاهم
Mentor A: يعني في كذا موديل غيروا غيروا انترفيس جدا يعني ما كانش كده وهو أصلا كان إسمه كيباك
Mentor A: مين بقى إحنا جناية لؤي في أيدي كونتيشنز.
Learner A1: فرنش.
Mentor A: فري بس بكوده بس يعني هي ممكن حاسة ممكن تديكوا حبة حلوين
Mentor A: وعدني أنت كده قلتلكم الفكرة في الكوت تعملوا أكاونت حتى اللي مش شغال فيتشر دي
Mentor A: يعمل يدي يدخل بأكاونت ويدي اللي شغال فيها ال بي آي آي كوندنيشن
Mentor A: دش ماشي بس ندي بقى إي كل ده مديكي لينك كل بتاعته
Mentor A: كل الريجن اللي فيه ومديك ون ده
Mentor A: مديك مني. ماك من ماك يعني إنتو محتاجين بجربوا شوفوا أنهي بيطلع حاجة حلوة في غوغل مديك بيه ثري
Mentor A: فاهمين بيكسبرس أمي هيومن فهل ده ممكن ينفع
Mentor A: ممكن اغرب يعني هي مش عارفة الصراحة.
Mentor A: أنا عايزة جيت ستارت من هنا أعمل تمام رقمي هنا ما فيش حاجة تديني تريال
Mentor A: إمم هنعمل إيه
Mentor A: من أسبوع جبن زملا طب هاكسب هنا يعني باكيديان.
Learner A1: ويورد لك يبعتلك ال اللي حنحط.
Mentor A: لأ مش أنا هجربها من ال يو آي نفسه
Mentor A: هو ليه كذا هو ليه كده
Mentor A: بص إحنا حنجرب بس أنا حاسة إن ده يعني
Mentor A: هبل يعني ده حاسه كتير قوي على اللي ينبعت يعني
Mentor A: طيب هو بياخد.
Learner A4: عامة كبومتو تمام يعني.
Mentor A: هو ما يعرفش إن هو يعرف أنت لازم تديلو آمنج
Mentor A: أو مثلا وهو أنا مثلك ما بينهم يعني لو إنت مثلا
Mentor A: ومثلا كونتينر فيه حاجات خلاص ده الفرس ده الفرس فريم آخر فريم بقى حتديلو التنين وهي أنا متها
Mentor A: فاهمة قصدي.
Learner A4: نو.
Mentor A: هو في المنشط كده معاهم.
Mentor A: كنت عايزة أعمل إيه
Mentor A: من فضلك
Mentor A: بصي هنا حتى سلطة فروموندو
Mentor A: لبن دكري
Mentor A: الكوطة أصلا. أنا أخلصت ممكن حد يجرب من عندو.
Learner A6: طيب ثواني رح تشتغل عندي.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A6: وإسمه صح؟
Learner A6: هو بالزبط ليكي لبرو بس.
Mentor A: مش عايزاك تجرب.
Learner A6: معلش.
Mentor A: معلش هديك ال إيمرج دي يعني حلوة صح حلوة الفجوة دي حلوة.
Learner A6: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي ونعمل تاني بس هو برضه بتختلف على يعني مثلا في نماذج بتاخد في نماذج ثانية
Mentor A: يعني نجرب بقى.
Learner A6: ثواني بس راوي.
Mentor A: اها منو يعني
Mentor A: هل ممكن هذه البطاقة عاملين
Mentor A: أوف؟
Mentor A: خذ طريق
Mentor A: لتر
Mentor A: على طول خلصت سكوت
Mentor A: صغر.
Learner A6: ماشي أنا أديلو الصورة بس ولا أعمل.
Mentor A: ثان سوري يا جماعة معلش صدقت وصلنا الفيلم.
Learner A6: أنا رفعت الشورى بس عايز أعرف أنا دخلت على الفيديو وحقيقة ك ميديا
Learner A6: بس مش عارف اللي هيدولوا
Mentor A: عشان جبتي عندي مش يقول له أني متت قلو أني متت بس جرب كده.
Learner A6: تمام جميل.
Mentor A: واختاري البتاع ون والدوري اختارها من تنين لفور.
Learner A6: ون وننين ل 4.
Mentor A: بخير وساوند أوف يعني مش.
Learner A6: أوكي الموديل هو اللي بيختاره لوحده ولا انا اختاره برضو.
Mentor A: لا أخت أنت هنا خلاص سيبوا كده عشان
Mentor A: الموديل هو قوته يعني هو في كذا حاجة بس خلينا نشوف
Learner A6: تمام
Learner A6: هو هو مش رودي الفيديو بس.
Mentor A: ياما قلبوها والله كنت والله كنت أدعان يسري بس.
Learner A6: يعني ممكن ساعة عشان كدا غيروا كمان الاسم بوقتها.
Mentor A: كنت أغير الموظف غير ولا هو.
Learner A6: هو مش جايبلي أساسا. إني أختار موديل عشان كدا كنت بسأل أنا مش.
Mentor A: هاي قصدها ولا اسم اف بي آي.
Learner A6: هو موديل أوتو بس هو ما فيش أساسا حاجة أقدر أختارها.
Mentor A: لا إزاي ما أنا هنا مختاره دوس هنا كده دوس عليها.
Learner A6: أيوا حتى لما بختار أي حاجة غيره هو بيجبلي برضه نفس الكلام اللي هو أنا محتاج أوب جريت.
Mentor A: طيب يبقى هو كده ما فيهاش أوبشن غير اللي انتو تجربوا بالإف بي آي.
Learner A6: إمم.
Mentor A: ما شاء الله أطلقوا الليك ينقربون.
Learner A6: بتعرفي.
Mentor A: المفروض لكم تعدي يعني أنا هنا لقيت إن أنا جيت مش عارف داخلة على ال
Mentor A: بس أنا أكاونت تاخد أنا ألريدي استخدمتها فا.
Learner A6: هو هو تقريبا أصلا كاتبينو في
Learner A6: نفسها ما عندهمش برضه في الفيديو أو لابس كده فيتشرز.
Mentor A: بي أوي ال سي آي كي
Mentor A: لا، هذا مش عارفة تو
Mentor A: طب شوف كدا يعني مش.
Learner A6: أقصد، إن هو يديني ال إي بي آي كي بس لما أجي أستخدمه حيقولي إنه مش في بلان بتاعتي.
Mentor A: ما ينفعش يديك ال بي آي كي غير لما
Mentor A: هو الجنرالات أكيد أكيد لازم يكون في فريز ما فيش حد بيعمل كده يعني
Mentor A: جرب كده جرب جرب ادخل اعمل جيت إي بي أوي.
Learner A6: من كوش منادي.
Mentor A: أنا بعتلك اللينك على على.
Learner A6: السلام عليكم حوالي جيتون.
Mentor A: ماني مودينز من شي فان اي او.
Learner A6: أنا دخلت عليه بي آي تي.
Mentor A: دورك قالك ده فري.
Learner A6: لأ هو أنا دخلت لقيت إنه في كنز بس
Learner A6: يعني هو حطيتلي إي بي أي كي بس لما بخش في فيو بلاندز وأقل الفيديوال الموجودة بخمستاشر يورو.
Mentor A: مش لا أفوكه
Mentor A: جوف هندا
Mentor A: هند بوكس كريم بقربوا منين بقى
Mentor A: منجرب منين برضه ال متخلفة دي مكرها
Mentor A: لي غرام ماشي؟ أوكي هو ده تقريبا في نماذج كثيرة بقى
Mentor A: وبيديك بال أب بي آي بتاعها حاجة شبه بس للفيديو صح ولا
Learner A1: فنفس الشكل.
Mentor A: أنا ده بجربه بس يعني مش جبن أمونت
Mentor A: توم دي جسم السادس من أنطوني بطاطس كنت ستاندرد
Mentor A: وده برضو بياخد.
Learner A6: بتاعه دلوقتي.
Mentor A: هو هو حاجة شبه قوي يعني حاسة بتاعه شبها جدا إمم
Mentor A: عاد شكرا
Mentor A: شو برضه بانتو بورت بندق كروز
Mentor A: طب إيه عندكوا أفكار وأفكار تانية تعمل إزاي الحوار ده
Mentor A: إنتو فهمتوا قصدي صح فهمتوا أنا عايزة أعمل إيه.
Learner A3: عشان حاسس إن ديونوفيشن.
Learner A1: بتتعمل ديو اي اكس على طول.
Mentor A: يعني مش واهم مين بكلمك.
Learner A1: كومبسيليشن.
Learner A3: أنا أنا بتكلم.
Learner A1: تم.
Mentor A: أنا عايزانة.
Learner A3: كنا تناقشنا، كنا اتناقشنا مع بعض في حتة إن إحنا نحاول بس نعمل يعني شغال بشكل كامل وأعتقد حضرتك فيدباك بتاعك إن هو دلوقتي شغال صح كده بس ممكن نحسن حتة آيكونز اللي طالعة دي بإستخدام طريقة تانية صح كده يعني إحنا بس محتاجين نحسن صح كده.
Mentor A: بالزبط.
Learner A3: هو عمر كنا كنا الموضوع كله إجمالا في البداية كان بيتكلم في حياتنا برضه نعمل فأعتقد الجزء ده ممكن أشتغل عليه في مرحلة ما يبقاش كله فقط حاجات معمولة قبل كده أو حاجات قبل يعني.
Mentor A: ليش ما أنا بسألك.
Learner A3: صح كده.
Mentor A: أيوة إيه الأفكار اللي عندكوا يعني حد قال دلوقتي.
Learner A3: ممكن يصير.
Mentor A: نطلع فيديو هش الرز بحتة 0.
Learner A3: يعني.
Mentor A: مش.
Learner A4: يعني أظن حريت الضوئي يعني عملنا كم تجربة حاليا والستين برضو يعني هو
Learner A4: أنا شايف إن هو حتبقى صعبة على إي جيمت اللي هو لكل جزئية يبدأ اللي هو فيها بالطريقة دي
Learner A4: في مودنز لو في تفضل.
Mentor A: مش حساها كله جزئية إنت البتاع اللي إنتو طلعتوني ده في الأربعة تقريبا أنا شفت 4 صور
Mentor A: مش صعبة نطلع الأربع أو حادث حرق.
Learner A4: ما هم ممكن يتحركوا بس انا بتكلم في جزئية يعني لما انتي لما حضرتك قولتي على
Learner A4: فكرة إن هو يفكر في الجزئية بتاعت البيل وهي جواها معرفش إيه دي أتوقع ممكن تنحل اللي يتبعت اللي هو معينة بس برضه مش غرانتيل هندرد بيرسنت اللي هو يطلع كل مرة
Learner A4: حاجة بالطريقة دي. حاجة تبقى سهلة.
Mentor A: أكيد طبعا مش غرانكيد في ممكن يطلع لك مثلا وحدة حلوة من التلاتة
Mentor A: بس أكيد يعني دي حاجة تانية المهم إن أنت تطلعها
Mentor A: يعني المهم إن إنت تطلعها حاجات بقى كل مرة طلعت دي بقى ممكن بس تتعمل تاني لو الموضوع ده خلاص في الشركة أو حاجة ده ممكن بقى يتعمله تاني إنه مثلا في حاجة قبل ما يطلع الفيديو
Mentor A: يعني ممكن يبقى في هيومان إن ذي لوب ما إحنا بنعمل تولز يبقى في الآخر طول تول عشان تسهل على الناس
Mentor A: إنها تطلع حاجة في شورتي. تايم
Mentor A: فممكن عادي ممكن عادي ممكن أدي هيومن بص أنا بشرح فيديو كذا كذا ده السين ده الفيديو اللي طلع أبروف ولا لأ يقولك لأ مش أبروف
Mentor A: فهو مثلا يروح يجرب فين
Mentor A: مش بتبقى ون شوت على قد ما هو ممكن ندخل هيومان عادي دي حاجة أصلا. كنا نعملها في
Mentor A: إن يبقى في حتة يعني مش بس بطلع الفيديو من زيرو توين من غير ما أخلي هيومن لا ممكن الحاجات اللي فيها سينس لازم هيومن هو فيها زي حتة
Mentor A: دي ممكن تبقى يعني عملها إنها تبقى حاجة اللي هو بيأثروب عليها فاهمة قصدي.
Mentor A: فعيب بس المهم إن أنت تعرف تطلع الحاجة ريليابل ولا لأ أكيد مش حتقدر تاخد حاجة يعني بكل رنايا
Mentor A: خصوصا الحصص اللي فيها نوفيشن والحدث فيها تايب لاين لأنه أصلا في العادي.
Learner A4: بالزبط.
Mentor A: فتمام إشتعلت دي ممكن ندخل حتة أسيت دي في حتة كده في البيب لاين أقف وأطلع نيوز مثلا الأربعة صور اللي هيطلعوا في الفيديو مش لازم لكل سين إيه بس ممكن مثلا أقوله ده حتة بتشرح زي ما إنتو كنتوا عاملين مثلا برينسيبل ون برانسيبل تو برانسيبل ثري برينسيبل فور
Mentor A: كابسوليشن مش عارفة وهرتس ومش عارفة إيه فأنا ممكن أقوله سين ون وأطلعله الصورة اللي طالعة أقول له ده سي ون بيشرح سين تو وأطلعه لو بلوكس كده
Mentor A: مش أبروف خلاص ممكن نعمل ممكن يسكبها يعمل أي حاجة لأي حاجة تانية.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: أنا بس عندي بس حد عنده إحساس كده يقدر يقول لي أهو دي حاجة نقدر نطلعها ولا ما نطلعهوش
Mentor A: أسامة مثلا.
Learner A4: على حد.
Learner A6: بصراحة يعني كل الفكرة بس أنا يعني كل اللي عمله سيرش عليك كلوز بتاعت الفيديو والكلام دوت كلها
Learner A6: وحتى لو كفيديو هي الفكرة كلها برضو. أنا كل بطلعها في يعني أنا قست نفسه بطلعه من التيكست بتاع الستين فهو بناء على التيكس ده بيقدر إنه يطلعلي.
Mentor A: طب هقول هيدا حقولك عن حاجات في ما ينفعش تطلع صورتين في السجن مش صورة وحدة.
Learner A6: دورتين.
Mentor A: يعني.
Learner A6: نعم.
Mentor A: يعني مثلا على حسب على حسب السين دي حاجات انتو شوفوها بقى جربوها يعني
Mentor A: مثلا على حسب السين هو مثلا أول سين ده كان بيشرح
Mentor A: هو باب برومتينغ إن هو إي دي سايد إن أنا عشان أشرح فيه كفيجوال
Mentor A: وطبعا دي برومتيك المفروض تحطلهم جايد لاينز كده يمشي عليها عشان يعرف إيه ويطلع ديسكريبشن صح
Mentor A: بقولك أول صورة مثلا صورة ماشي
Mentor A: تاني صورة صورة مثلا بوكس كده مثلا صغيرة
Mentor A: لو إحنا معنا الإثنين دول ينفع أحرك صورة البوكس دي ناحية ال ناحية البل مثلا
Mentor A: ريو واي هلأ بإتش اميل ملاءأة.
Learner A6: الصراحة مش متأكد المعمول هو بيبقى ستيك شوية الحوار انو هو يعني مش يعني.
Mentor A: بصراحة ممكن انساه.
Learner A6: الله يسلمك.
Mentor A: أيوة.
Learner A6: اللي أنا عامله.
Mentor A: ، ما ينفعش أخلي يكتبلي حتة كده جوز كريب صغيرة. خالص أديله الصورة دي والصورة دي ومثلا ديسكريبشن ويطلعلي جو كريبت
Mentor A: مثلا الصورة دي بتتحرك ناحية الصورة دي أو في أي بتحصل
Mentor A: آي ثينك دي تبقى مثلا 10 سطور كود بس ولا
Learner A6: هو يعني.
Mentor A: يبقى محطوطة مكان.
Learner A4: من العادي بالنسبة لفيديو إيديوكيشن هيبقى طالع
Learner A4: حيبقى واخد يعني ريندر و سبيسكيشن معينة للود عشان يقدر يرن لأن إحنا بالشكل ده إحنا مش بالرندر عندنا وبعد كده بندي للكليينت
Learner A4: يا عمي السيرفر مش هو اللي بيرندر
Learner A4: ال كليينت عنده هو اللي بيرندلك.
Learner A4: بالزبط فدي حتبقى شوية على اليونزف فده معناه اللي هو السكوب حيقل شويه.
Mentor A: طب إيه يعني بصراحة يعني مش عارفة إيه أنتم من شغله.
Learner A4: هي ممكن هي ممكن هي ممكن تحصل بس مش يعني حضرتك متخيلها بس.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: يعني إحنا ممكن ممكن ندي كذا صورة في دي حاجة سهلة ممكن نخلي الصورة معبرة تمام.
Mentor A: ما ما أنا عايزاه حتى لو معبرة مبيتا كابسوليشن
Mentor A: معرفش مش عارفة يعني أنا حاسة الصورة اللي عندي بتاع دي معبرة أكتر
Mentor A: على مثلا الصورة اللي محطوط مش عارفة.
Learner A4: ما إحنا إحنا ممكن نوصلها للجزئية بتاعت حضرتك
Learner A4: بس مش للدرجة زي ما بقول لحضرتك هو ده دعم دعم معلوماتي أنا اشتغلت ويبدي اللي اشتغلت
Learner A4: يعني حطيت إيديك كذا حاجة فالأنا أعرفه في الجزئية دي لا بس.
Mentor A: أعرف الصراحة.
Mentor A: طيب.
Learner A4: إيه طيب كومنت تاني.
Mentor A: دي الأول عندكوا في الأول إي إي مشكلة إن حد يطلع فيديو طويل بالإي آي حاجتين
Mentor A: أو ممكن تلاتة السنك اللي هو كلام يبقى ماشي مع
Mentor A: دي أكتر حاجة أصلا لسه لحد دلوقتي في قشور كبيرة فيها
Mentor A: بعيدا بقى عننا والحاجات اللي بتطلع دي لا يعني فيش تبقى حتة إينوفيشن وكده.
Learner A4: مهو علشان كده يعني بقول لحضرتك حتة فيجوز عشان تبقى جاية بالشكل ال بالشكل كواليتي العالية بالنسبة مثلا ل 1 لسه بجانب فإنت. عايزة تعمليلوا للإمادج أو لل
Learner A4: للبروتوكول اللي هو بيتطرح أو أيا كان يعني التكنولوجي اللي هو عايز يعرف عنها
Learner A4: ده تبقى صعبة شوية ان هي تبقى فولي جميلة باي آي
Learner A4: يعني أنا مثلا أنا اشتغلت جرافيك وعملت لعبة قبل كده
Learner A4: فمثلا الكركترز نو واي اللي أنا كنت مثلا، أخلي كله يعملها. أنا كان الأول بديسكريبشن والديكريبشن ده بخش على موقع تاني اللي هو يعملي فول بودي. و موفمنت تبقى عاملة ازاي الثانية تبقى عاملة ازاي ومن على الجنب أعمل إزاي.
Mentor A: عشان تطلع حاجة زي كده قعدت قد
Learner A4: حتبقى محتاجة في الأول ثانيا، يعني علشان الكلام ده كله يتعمله مثلا محتاج جهاز تقيل
Learner A4: نفس الوقت بيقعد بتاع دقيقتين تلاتة
Learner A4: ده لو لو الجهاز تمام لو هو عدم الجهاز
Learner A4: يعني مثلا لما أنا كنت بعمل الأنيميشن بتاع اللعب ده الجهاز حرفيا عندي كان بيموت
Learner A4: والجهاز بتاعته يعني مش قليلة خالص
Learner A4: بس هي هي دي النقطة مش اكتر
Learner A4: هي ممكن تتعمل بس مش بالكواليتي اللي حضرتك بتتكلمي عنها مش هو
Learner A4: يعني احنا ممكن نجرب كده في مثلا في الجزئية بتاعة مصطفى بعد ما احنا ناخد يعني آخر كود اسامة بحيث ان احنا نبقى شغالين على
Learner A4: آخر حاجة ممكن يلعب في في البروم
Learner A4: في نفس الوقت برضو عمر يلعب في الكومس بحيث ان الصور اللي طالعة هما عليها بنفسهم اللي هو إحنا مثلا 60 ده
Learner A4: دي بالنسبة لي كبدينال هتبقى أكثر حاجة أو بيتشرح.
Mentor A: أنا مش بقول على بيغينر أو حتة دي مش.
Learner A4: ا.
Mentor A: أنت مطلعها. أنا أنا كحد هأتفرج على حاجة مش برضه إن الفيديو مش حتبقى هي برضه كوين ممكن تنزل على تيك توك ممكن تنزل إنستغرام كوين ده يعني.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ليش هندرد بيرسنت إيديوكيشنال طويلة تنحط في.
Learner A4: أيوه أيوه.
Mentor A: سيدي.
Learner A4: في.
Mentor A: تتفرج على حاجة زي كده إنت عايز تشوف إيه يعني إنت إنت تخيل كده لو فيديو زي يطلعلك عالإنستغرام.
Learner A4: مازال دا اللي انا بتكلم فيه مع حضرتك
Learner A4: دا اللي انا بتكلم فيه أنا مش مش ممكن انا مش عارف اوصل للبوينت بتاعتي
Learner A4: بس يعني ححاول اقولها تاني
Learner A4: اللي حضرتك بتقوليه إحنا ممكن نوصل اللي هو يوصل مع نفسه كده في بتاعه اللي هو لما أنا أديله فهو عارف، اهو مبدأ 1 2 3 ممكن أعمله فيجوالي 1 أو ما يعرفش حاجة بشكل الفيلاية دي
Learner A4: وجواها ليش أنا ما أسلم.
Mentor A: هو حيطلع لي صورة فيها زي زي مطلعهم عشان تجيبتيلي.
Mentor A: أنا مش ده اللي عايزاه بقى مش ده اللي عايزاه.
Learner A4: عايزة تتحرك.
Mentor A: عايزة عايزة حاجة بكون فيها رايحة جاية
Mentor A: يعني يعني زي ما قلتلك مثلا السين ده يطلعله صورتين وأحاول أحرك الصورة دي جوا الصورة دي جي إف أحاول أطلع حاجة جي إف
Mentor A: يعني.
Learner A4: هو إحنا إحنا ممكن إحنا ممكن يعني أنا من ناحيتي زي ما
Learner A4: صعبة شوية لأن الجزئية بتاعة هتبقى صعبة شوية فإحنا ممكن نديها ترييل عادي جدا.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: ما عنديش أي مشكلة في الحتة دي بالعكس يعني هو لو وصلنا لحاجة زي دي ده حاجة حتعلينا جدا. وفي نفس الوقت شكله أحلى بكثير
Learner A4: في الأول في الآخر يعني إحنا نستفيد برضه من اللي احنا طلعنا برودكت محترم وشكله كويس جدا والناس كمان لو مثلا انتو هستخدموه عندكوا في الشركة أو إحنا عملتو 1، 2 3 كويس،
Learner A4: فإحنا ما عندناش مشكلة إن إحنا نديله سترايل عادي.
Mentor A: طيب عندي سؤال بص أنا برضه معلش صراحة أوي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: اف بي جي أنا سألتية قال لي إس بي جي دي ممكن أن تكون نيميتد.
Learner A4: هي ممكن تبقى مية جنيه.
Mentor A: يعني هي كود بتاع كود أو.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: حلو فأنت هل ممكن بقى تعرف؟ تطلع الكود بتاعها ده حاجة شبه كدا.
Learner A4: لا هنزلها في تريلي عشان
Learner A4: لأن الفكرة يعني حركة أكتر واحدة عارفة أكيد بتبعتي الكود ده أو الكود اللي احنا كاتبينه هو بيروح يبعتله اللي احنا عاملينلو ديزاين بناء على اللي داخلة كلها مع بعضها متربطة.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: فهو حيبعت
Learner A4: البرونت هنقوله عايزينك مثلا انت تجيب إيماج نفسها أو تعمل إيماج نفسها طب مهو هو محتاج رسم
Learner A4: هو ممكن لو هو لو هو مثلا راح من نفسه كده دور على الإنترنت
Learner A4: وشاف الريفينتس إحنا إيه اللي حيعرفنا منور الشاشة.
Mentor A: الإنترنت. هو يكتب الكود بتاعها.
Learner A4: ما هو حيكتب الكود بتاعنا عشان يكتب الكود بتاعها هيجيب منين الشكل نفسه أو.
Mentor A: لا هو بقى يرتقي بص.
Learner A4: ما هو حيرتجل.
Mentor A: شوف هيطلع
Mentor A: شوف الارتجال بتاعه ده عشان يطلعلك حتة دلوقتي. انت اديته سيم كلين ده فهو شاف إن سين ونشرح وديته كمان أسد ديسكريبشن
Mentor A: قلت له أنا عايزة تبقى مثلا عايزة تبقى بس بطريقة ديسكريبتف شوية عشان تبقى مش بتتعامل مع إيماج.
Learner A4: هو.
Mentor A: كيف حالك فتقوله؟ أنا عايز مثلا أنا عايز ده سيم بيحصل تقول له في أسيد ديسكريبشن
Mentor A: أنا عايز صورة بل تدخل جوا.
Mentor A: هل أنا.
Learner A4: حيوصل للنقطة دي إزاي.
Mentor A: يعني يوصل.
Learner A4: يعني هو حيوصل للتفكير اللي الجزئية اللي هي فل وبيدخل جواها ده منين يعني أنا دلوقتي.
Mentor A: لأ أنا حاسة إن هو سمارت أنوف إن هو يفهم إن أنا لو بشرح
Mentor A: أصل أنا كهيوم هاو أنا كهيومان
Mentor A: أول حاجة جات في مالي إيه أو إنت أول ما قلتلي جاءت في الماي صورة البنت.
Learner A4: ما هو ذكي بس هو يبقى معتمد على نفس الوقت الممري هو معتمد على 1,000,000 الف حاجه تانيه حضرتك عارفاها أكيد
Learner A4: بالنسبة له يبقى كبير جدا إحنا بالنسبالنا زي الحتة دي
Learner A4: بس مش شرط اللي هو أول حاجة يوصله لو كده.
Mentor A: طيب طب حنفترض إن هو عرف يطلع ديسكريبشن.
Learner A4: لو قضايا.
Mentor A: كويس. أنا بقول راح طلعلي زي ما أنا بقولك طلعلي الجملة دي
Mentor A: وفي داتا تدخل جواه لل ديسكريبش
Mentor A: خلاص ده ينفع أطلع نقود اكس ال واعملوا راندرنغ في في.
Learner A4: آي ثينك؟ مش مش حيبقى فيها مشكلة.
Mentor A: ماشي بس الكوت ده حيطلع برضه يعني حتديلو ده وتقوله طلعه لي اكس ام.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي هيطلع اكتمال هيطلع من نفسه تمام
Learner A4: لو حتى اللي هو يوصل اللي هو يعمل مثلا كود مع نفسه يعملو ويشتغل تمام هي الفكرة اللي هو يوصل للمرحلة دي أصلا يوصل لطريقة التفكير دي.
Mentor A: طيب قراص ميش طيب.
Learner A4: ممكن نوصل لها فين.
Mentor A: خلاص أوكي طيب عشان ركاب كده إمم
Mentor A: أول حاجة بس هي حاجات البيزكس اللي هو زي ما قلتلكم ما تتكلمش في البداية بتاعت الإنتر دي والحتة بتاعة.
Mentor A: أهلا بك.
Learner A4: إنتو سامعين سامعين كله مركز وسامع.
Learner A6: فرنش.
Learner A4: من علشان علشان ما يحصلش وما يحصلش بس علشان انا ممكن انسى حاجة ممكن حاجة مني فكله يبقى سامي.
Mentor A: خلاص دي أول أول حاجة أول معلومة
Mentor A: ثاني حاجة تاني حاجة كله يمر دلوقتي مفيش غير اللي ناوز حتة ال توينتي فور صح.
Learner A4: دي أنا يعني أولا وكما يرفع على طول من
Learner A4: وممكن النهارده بكرة بالكتير ان شاء الله ابعتلك فيديو على البتاع اللي احنا طلعناه.
Mentor A: النهاردة بكرة بتكتيري عمر قبل يوم السبت عشان أنا يوم السبت.
Learner A4: لا ده أكيد.
Mentor A: قصة ارتيبل.
Learner A4: تمام تمام.
Mentor A: خلاص قبل يوم السبت طيب أول بقى يحصل أنا عايزاك كل خلاص كل حاجة تبقى على مين
Mentor A: وتعملي تاج للكومي عايزة تأكد تكتبلي في الجنون.
Mentor A: شوف إزاي كأنك بتعلم الكوميدي كأنك بتعلم الأستاذ دي في هذا لا.
Learner A4: ده ده أول مرة دي أول ستاج يعني كاملة يبقى فيها كل الليزون شغالين وكده.
Mentor A: ,
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: نضيع يعني عمها إن دي خلاص ده اللي طلع منها
Mentor A: المهم أوي بس مهمة قوي قبل قبل اي يعني خلاص أول ما تخلص ده إمبي فور ده جاهز والكل يتربط مع بعض وتجرب. ويطلع حاجة
Mentor A: خلاص تعمل تاج.
Learner A4: من.
Mentor A: من.
Learner A4: يطلع حاجة عامة من غير.
Mentor A: يعني زي.
Learner A4: تمام ما فيش.
Mentor A: ماشي بس بعد بس ما أسامة يعمل اللي هي بتاعة والكلام ده.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: الجاية بقى ماشي بقى يعني حنرتجل بقى
Mentor A: يعني إنت دلوقتي عايزة تدور على فيديو جنرست
Mentor A: عندك إن إنت تجرب يطلعلك إسمه ده اكس ام ال
Mentor A: عندك إن إنت تجار يعني كل اتنين كده.
Learner A4: هي إيه.
Mentor A: يرتجل.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي الارتجال ده هيبقى مدته قد إيه مش كلها طبعا الارتجال ده إنتو الستاند بتاعكوا إمتى 5.
Learner A4: إيه التنين 5 ، يوم الاتنين الساعة 5.
Mentor A: ماشي حد عنده مشكلة تمانية.
Learner A4: بالليل.
Mentor A: أو 9 9 بالليل.
Learner A4: تمام أنا بالنسبة لي كمان.
Mentor A: الباقيين.
Learner A4: دول.
Learner A6: من.
Learner A4: سبانيا.
Mentor A: 9 بالليل.
Learner A4: مش.
Mentor A: أوكي خلاص يبقى معاكم الحد كله والاثنين كل.
Learner A3: من الجواب.
Mentor A: الاثنين بقى في الستاند. أنا هدخل أشوف بقى اللي بيحصل.
Learner A4: ما.
Mentor A: خلاص يعني أنا محتاجة يوم الاثنين بس يوم الاثنين ده في الآخر
Mentor A: أخو لما يدخل في الستاند محتاجة كل 2 بقى يقولوا لي إحنا جربنا كذا وكذا وكذا بصي ده الأول بتاع اللي إحنا جربناه.
Learner A4: أنا بس.
Mentor A: وحش أو حلو يعني سواء وحش أو حلو أشوفه وأشوف اللي إنتو مثلا جربتوه لحد
Mentor A: وطلعله حاجة أشوف كل عايزاه تبقى موجودة ما حدش يطلع تريله يمسحها
Mentor A: اكتبوا. اسم التريال خذوا بقى برانشات بقى مختلفة
Mentor A: مش يسموها بقى سموها مثلا ده برانش بجرب كيلينغ ده برانش بجرب ده برانش بجرب كذا تعميم.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: اسحبوا برانشات بقى مين عايز يسأل.
Learner A4: عايز كنت عايز بس نحرك على موضوع اليوم بلانينغ
Learner A4: وانا الوقت احضرش كويز واحضر ميتينغ كويز.
Mentor A: بص هو أنا أنا صعب علي جدا. إن أنا أخروني حد بالذات لأن زي ما هو إسمه سبرينت بلانينغ الأول يعني حد برضه في الشغل بيبقى عندي سترينت بلانغ
Mentor A: عشان هي بداية الأسبوع فبتدوني مكربسة جدا فما أقدرش أجله وما أقدرش أخليه بالليل عشان كدا إنتو تعملوا إيه الصبح
Mentor A: فهي إشاعة يعني حتى لو هتدخل هتدخل تسمع بس يعني مش لازم يبقى فهو فعلا بيبقى صعب أوي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: يعني مستندة بس أنا براحتكو بندخل 8 بالعشرة ساعات داخل على الحداشر أصلا.
Learner A4: اها.
Mentor A: عادي مشانينغ بيبقى صعب.
Learner A4: كويس، فهمت.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A4: تمام ياسين.
Mentor A: بس كده وأستنى أديس يوم الجمعة يوم الجمعة.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: ثانك يو يا شباب، شكرا برد الشغل بجد حلوة قوي.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A4: من خلال.
Mentor A: باي.
Learner A4: أيوه.
Learner A4: هو أنا أحمد منصور أعملها ديليفير ليكي يعني
Learner A4: ما اعرفش يعني معرفش بتاعتي قاللي اللي هي هتبقى.
Mentor A: هو أنت عملت إيه إنت مش بعت بي ار للثورة وخلاص ولا اللي حصل.
Learner A4: هو أنا ما كنش في حاجة جديدة، أصلا. وكنت طالب مني حاجات أنا ألريدي أعملها؟
Mentor A: طب ممكن تبعتلي ميس كفشات.
Learner A4: ابعت المسج اللي هو بعتهالي يعني.
Mentor A: أوه، فرشات هنا في الميتينغ.
Learner A4: ماشي تمام
Learner A4: مع السلامة.
Mentor A: ثبت إيمتى بس انت دي.
Learner A4: ببداية الأسبوع.
Mentor A: فوكس.
Learner A4: طيب يعني عم أنا سلم إيه يعني الكلام ده أنا ألريدي اعمل.
Mentor A: مش أنا كنت كان بقية، وكنت.
Learner A4: ما هو تمام أنا ألريدي عملت الكلام ده.
Mentor A: ماشي مش لسة انت عندك حتة ال
Mentor A: تو إمبري فور والكلام ده حتعملها. أنت وهتدفعها
Mentor A: فأنت في حاجات هو تعمل بس.
Learner A4: أيوه أنا قصدي يعني حضرتك ولا بعملها ولا.
Mentor A: سارة. لا، أنا ما بعملش حاجة مش أنا سارة فكك منه، فك ما بالك فوك منه.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: من.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Mentor A: بس يعني حاول بس تنجز يعني حاول تنجز كده عشان هو أصلا كاتب إن ديدلاين الخميس يعني تنعش.
Learner A4: هو هو المفروض كمان شوية يعني تمام.
Mentor A: أنا خلاص.
Learner A4: أنا هبعت له.
Learner A6: إلى المرور.
Learner A4: أنا هبعت لها آخر حاجة.
Mentor A: ماشي خلص أوكي.
Learner A4: 1,000.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي ثانك يو يا شباب إنه باي باي.
Learner A4: الله.
Learner A6: بوي.
Learner A4: كل عارفها يعمل إيه.
Learner A6: أنا حروح حالا. أخلص حاجة.
Learner A4: هي قالت حاجة كتير فا أنا اللي فهمتو ان احنا نص السفر.
Learner A4: أنت حاولت تطلع مور ديسكريبت ومصطفى حاول يطلع مور ديسكريبتف سيم بلانينغ وسامى الكومنت اللي هي لسه.
Learner A6: بحاول أخلص بسرعة السويد عشان الساعة تناشر
Learner A6: عشان يعني هي الفكرة إنه يعني الصورة مش حتاخد الحاجات دي في الإعتبار هي عايزة أهم حاجة الحاجات اللي عملت
Learner A6: أدهملها بعد كده حشتغلوا على طول على ال وبس يعني بسيطة يعني بإذن الله.
Learner A4: سهلة إن شاء الله.
Learner A6: أنا شاهد.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A4: كراشي.